long distance or phone charges may apply
now a health science committee hearing
on the search for extraterrestrial life
this is an
be called to hour but that's the trend
that's the chance you take
[Music]
the committee on science space and
technology will come to order and
welcome to today's hearing
astrobiology and the search for life in
the universe a couple of the preliminary
announcements one is that i want to
thank
c-span for covering this hearing today
that shows the importance of the hearing
in a lot of respects and i want to thank
all the students from herndon high
school here here as well i understand
you had a choice of hearings
to attend in fact you could attend
almost any hearing you wanted to and you
chose this one because you thought it
was the most interesting
and actually
that is one of the purposes of today's
hearing and that is to inspire students
today
to be the scientist of tomorrow and who
knows we may have some of those
scientists in the audience right now who
will be inspired by what they hear
to study astrobiology or perhaps some of
the other sciences as well so we
appreciate your attendance
i'll recognize myself for an opening
statement and then the ranking number as
well
as we discover more planets around the
stars in our own galaxy it is natural to
wonder if we may finally be on the brink
of answering the question are we alone
in the universe
finding other sentient life in the
universe would be the most significant
discovery in human history
scientists estimate that there are 80
billion stars in the milky way galaxy
today more than 1700 nearby planets have
been found by the kepler space telescope
last month astronomers discovered the
first earth-like planet orbiting its
star at a distance where liquid water
could be present a condition thought
essential to life
called kepler 186f it is only 10 percent
larger than the earth and about 490
light years away
the transiting exoplanet survey
satellite which will launch in 2017 and
the james webb space telescope launching
in 2018
will help scientists discover more
planets with potential bio signatures
the united states has pioneered the
field of astrobiology and continues to
lead the world in this type of research
a sample of professional papers
published in science magazine between
1995 and 2013 illustrates the
significant growth and growing
popularity of the field of astrobiology
between 1995 and 2012 the number of
papers published on astrobiology
increased 10 times and the number of
scientific reports that cited
astrobiology increased 25 times
astrobiology is a serious subject
studied by serious scientists around the
world
reflecting this interest next september
the library of congress and nasa will
hold a two-day astrobiology symposium on
what the societal impacts could be of
finding microbial complex or intelligent
life in the universe
whether life exists on other planets in
the universe continues to be a matter of
debate among scientists
around the world a number of astronomers
listen to naturally occurring radio
frequencies they try to filter out the
cosmic noise and interference of
human-made satellites and spacecraft to
find anomalies that could be signals
from civilizations elsewhere in the
universe
the allen telescope array at the seti
institute financed by microsoft
co-founder paul allen
and the arecibo telescope in puerto rico
are two well-known locations for
conducting radio astronomy searches for
life in the universe
recently radio astronomers have detected
pulsed signals that last only a few
milliseconds these fast radio bursts as
they are called have caused scientists
to speculate as to their cause
some scientists hypothesize they could
be from stars colliding or from an
extraterrestrial intelligence source
other astronomers search for laser light
pulses instead of radio waves
researchers at the seti optical
telescope run by the harvard smithsonian
center for astrophysics the columbus
optical study observatory and the
university of california at berkeley
among others use optical telescopes to
try to detect nanosecond pulses or
flashes of light distinct from pulsars
or other natural naturally occurring
phenomenon
i hope today's hearing will enable us to
learn more about how research and
astrobiology continues to expand this
fascinating frontier
the unknown and unexplored areas of
space spark human curiosity
americans and others around the world
look up at the stars and wonder if we
are alone or is there life on other
planets that concludes my opening
statement in the ranking member the
gentleman from texas ms johnson is
recognized for hers
thank you very much mr chairman and good
morning
in the interest of saving time i will
forego making an opening statement
and instead i'll simply want to welcome
dr shostak and dr wertheimer to this
morning's hearing on the search for life
including intelligent life
and outer space
uh you both are distinguished
researchers and i know that you will
have thoughtful testimony
to present and this afternoon we'll
determine whether we'll have researchers
to continue this so thank you and i
yield back
thank you miss johnson and i'd like to
introduce our witnesses at this point
our first witness dr seth shostak the
senior astronomer at the seti institute
in mountain view california he has held
this position since 2001. dr shostak has
spent much of his career conducting
radio astronomy research on galaxies dr
shostak has written more than 400
published magazine and web articles on
various topics in astronomy technology
film and television he is also edited
and contributed to nearly a dozen
scientific and popular astronomy books
he has authored four books including
sharing the universe perspectives on
extraterrestrial life
and confessions of an alien hunter a
scientist search for extraterrestrial
intelligence
you can hear him each week as host of a
one hour long radio program on
astrobiology entitled big picture
science
dr shostak received his bachelor's in
physics from princeton and his phd in
astrophysics from the california
institute of technology
our second witness dr dan wertheimer has
worked at the space sciences laboratory
at uc berkeley since 1983.
he is currently the director of several
of the lab centers including the seti
research center in the center for
astronomy signal processing and
electronics research
additionally mr wertheimer serves as
chief scientist for the lab's seti at
home program and associate director of
their berkeley wireless research center
mr wertheimer co-authored seti 2020 and
was the editor of bioastronomy
molecules microbes and extraterrestrial
life
and astronomical and biochemical origins
and the search for life in the universe
his research has been featured in many
broadcast news stories such as on abc
and cbs and many major newspapers and
magazines his work also has reached a
younger audience through scholastic
weekly a science magazine for kids
mr wertheimer received his bachelor's
and master's degrees in physics and
astronomy from san francisco state
university
i'll recognize to start us off today dr
shostak and then we'll go to mr
wertheimer
thank you congressman smith for the
opportunity to uh to be here i'm just
going to give you a few big picture
uh thoughts on the search for life and
in particular intelligent life the kind
of life that could uphold its side of
the conversation as opposed to the
microbial sort of life this is obviously
a subject of great interest to many
people let me just back up and say that
when you read in the paper about the
discovery of new planet or something uh
water on mars you're looking at one of
three horses in a race to be the first
to find some extraterrestrial biology
the first horse is simply to find it
nearby and that's where the big money is
rovers on mars the moons of the outer
solar system there are at least a half a
dozen other worlds that might have life
in our solar system the chances of
finding it i think are good and if that
happens it'll happen in the next 20
years depending on the financing the
second horse in that race is to build
very large instruments that can sniff if
you will the atmospheres of planets
around other stars and maybe find oxygen
in the atmosphere or methane which as
you know is produced by cows and pigs
and things like that but biology in any
case and so you could find pigs in space
i suppose that's again a project
depending on funding that could yield
results in the next two decades the
third horse in that race is seti search
for extraterrestrial intelligence and
that idea if you've seen the movie
contact you know what the idea is it's
to eavesdrop on signals that are either
deliberately or accidentally leaked off
somebody else's world that makes sense
because in fact even we only a hundred
years after tesla and marconi and the
invention of practical radio we already
have the technology that would allow us
to send bits of information across light
years of distance to putative
extraterrestrials uh let me just tell
you why i think they're out there by the
way that is is you know it's unproven
whether there's any life on earth that's
the situation today you've heard me say
twice now that i think that situation is
going to change within everyone's
lifetime in this room okay and the
reason is where the the universe is very
effective with habitats for life uh
congressman smith has mentioned the
number of stars in our galaxy
with respect that number is actually
rather larger it's it's something like
two to four hundred billion stars but we
now know that seventy at least seventy
percent of them have planets recent
results from nasa's kepler telescope an
astoundingly successful instrument
suggests that one in five stars may have
planets that are cousins of the earth
what that means is that in our own
galaxy they're tens of billions of other
planets that
are the kind you might want to build
condos on and live all right okay tens
of billions and if that isn't adequate
for your uh requirements let me point
out there are 150 billion other galaxies
we can see with our telescopes each with
a similar complement of earth-like
worlds what that means is that
the the numbers are so astounding that
if this is the only planet in which not
only life but intelligent
life has arisen then we are
extraordinarily exceptional it's like
buying trillions of lottery tickets and
none of them is a winner that would be
very very unusual and although everybody
likes to think that they're special and
i'm sure you all are maybe we're not
that special certainly the history of
astronomy shows that every time we
thought we were special we were wrong
so what has been done so far we have had
various kinds of radio searches
i won't detail the technology we've
looked at parts of this
much of the sky at fairly low
sensitivity over a limited range of
radio wavelengths uh radio sections of
the band we have looked in particular
directions at a few thousand star
systems in other words we've just begun
the search the fact we haven't found
anything means nothing it's like looking
for megafauna in africa and giving up
after you've only examined one city
block and the reason the search has been
so cramped so constricted so far is
simply to be honest the fact that
there's no funding for this it's all
privately funded the total number of
people in the world
that do seti for a living is fewer than
the number of people in any row in the
audience here behind me that's the world
total for this endeavor when are we
going to find them you've already heard
me suggest that that may happen rather
quickly let me just point out two other
things one this is very interesting to
the public because they've seen
extraterrestrials on television
and in the movies all their lives okay
that also gives it a certain giggle
factor it's very easy to make fun of
this on the other hand it would have
been easy to make fun of ferdinand
magellan's idea to sail around the earth
or captain cook to map the south pacific
it's exploration that's what this is the
consequences are always
say salubrious find that there's life
out there intelligent life would
calibrate our position in the universe
it would as congressman smith says
probably be the greatest discovery that
humankind could ever make and what's
important is this is the first
generation that has both the knowledge
and the technology to do that
thank you dr shostak and mr wertheimer
thanks for the opportunity
thank you for the opportunity to talk to
you about this question are we alone is
anybody out there um can you guys uh
show the the slides i wanna i wanna walk
you through some of the seti experiments
that we and other people are doing um so
as seth mentioned this nasa kepler
mission
from that we've learned that there are a
trillion planets in our milky way galaxy
that's more planets than there are stars
lots of places for life and we've
learned that a lot of these planets are
what we call goldilocks planets at the
right distance where it's not too hot
not too cold rocky planet some have
liquid water
so there could be a lot of life out
there
so how we getting in touch well one of
the ideas is that earthlings have been
sending off radio television radar
signals out into space for the last 75
years the early television shows like i
love lucy ed sullivan have gone past 10
000 stars the nearby stars have seen the
simpsons
so uh you could turn that around if if
we're broadcasting maybe other
civilizations are sending signals in our
direction either leaking signals the way
that we unintentionally send off signals
or maybe a deliberate signal
they could be sending laser signals and
there are a number of projects looking
for for laser signals this is a project
at harvard university a very clever
project this is a project at lick
observatory there's also a project at
the
in hawaii at the telescope looking for
laser signals
people are also looking for radio
signals our group uses the world's
largest radio antenna we call it a radio
telescope this is the arecibo telescope
in puerto rico it's a thousand feet in
diameter it's holds 10 billion bowls of
corn flakes we haven't actually tried
that
the
it's operated by the national science
foundation and most astronomers would be
lucky to use this telescope a year a day
or two a year we figured out a way to
use the telescope at the same time that
other scientists are using it so we can
actually collect data all year round all
day we're collecting data right now as
we talked to you
now that is actually a problem so even
though we get the world's largest
telescope all year round
it creates an enormous amount of data
and to analyze that data we ask
volunteers for help
they if you you can help us by
running a program on your home computer
your laptop or your desktop computer you
install a a program called seti at home
it's a screen saver program and the way
we take the data from the world's
largest telescope when we break it up
into little pieces everybody gets a
different piece of the sky to analyze
and you install this program and it pops
up when you go out for a cup of coffee
and you and the computer uh goes through
the data looking through all the
different frequencies and signal types
this is what it looks like when it's
running on your computer at home it
takes a few days to analyze data looking
for interesting signals and then when it
finds interesting signals it sends them
back to berkeley and then you get a new
chunk of data a different part of the
sky to work on uh if you are the lucky
one that finds that faint murmur from
distant civilization um you might get
the nobel prize but there's a catch the
nobel prize you have to maybe share with
a lot of people there are millions of
people that have downloaded the steady
home screensaver they're split up into
200 countries
it's together the volunteers have formed
one of the
most powerful supercomputers on the
planet and they've enabled the most
sensitive search for extraterrestrial
signals that that anybody's ever done so
we're very grateful to the volunteers
and and now we've made that more general
so that you can participate in not just
steady with your home computer but you
can uh participate in lots of projects
there's climate prediction projects
there's a gravity wave project
there's protein folding you can look for
malaria drugs hiv drugs cancer drugs and
you can allocate how you want your spare
computing cycles to be used on your home
computer
one of the new projects that we're
working on is called panchromatic seti
and we're asking universities and
observatories around the world to look
at a lot of different wavelength bands a
lot of different frequencies we're
targeting the very nearest stars and
we're trying to cover all the different
bands that come through the earth's
atmosphere we're looking at radio
frequencies we're looking at infrared
frequencies or wavelengths and we're
looking at also optical frequencies
looking for laser signals
and this will be a extremely
comprehensive search because we've got
eight different telescopes that we're
using
and looking at all these different bands
but only targeting the nearby stars
another project that we're just
launching this year is called
interplanetary eavesdropping and the
idea of this project is that there may
be signals going back and forth between
two planets in a distant solar system uh
for instance uh maybe eventually we'll
have machines or people on mars and
we'll have radio communication or laser
communication between our two planets
we'll put it
put it the other way a distant
civilization may have uh
colonized a planet in their own solar
system and there may be radio or laser
signals going back and forth between
those two planets and now with the
kepler spacecraft we know exactly when
two planets in a distant solar system
are in lined up with earth so we can
schedule our observations and target
that and see if we can intercept those
signals going back and forth between two
distant planets we're using that the
green bank telescope in west virginia to
do that experiment well we haven't found
et's so far but we made a lot of
interesting discoveries we discover a
planet made out of solid diamond uh
we've made the first maps the black hole
of the center galaxy these instruments
are used in all kinds of things in brain
research which may eventually control
prosthetic arms but we haven't found et
so far we're still working on we're just
getting in the game we've only had radio
100 years we're just learning how to do
it it's like looking for a needle in a
haystack but i'm optimistic in the long
run the reason i'm optimistic in the
long run uh is that that the city is
limited by
computing technology which is growing
exponentially it's it's limited by
telescope technology uh the china is
building a huge telescope bigger than
arecibo
the australians and south africans the
europeans are working on a huge
telescope made out of thousands of of
dishes combined to make a giant
telescope
and i think i'll stop there i've got a
couple of poems that i could read you
from the volunteers but i'm out of time
thank you very much
thank you mr wertheimer uh thank you
both for your excellent testimony and
actually you've anticipated my questions
a little bit but i'd still like to go
forward with them and let me address the
first question to both of you all but
starting with dr shostak and it is this
kind of a two-part question uh what do
you think and i can anticipate your
answer a little bit on the basis of your
statement but what do you think is the
possibility
of
microbial life being found in the
universe or intelligent life being found
in the universe so the and the so the
first question goes to the possibility
the second question would be what do you
think is the likelihood
of finding either microbial life or
intelligent life in the universe two
different kind of questions dr shostak
well the uh the probability of life of
course it's hard to estimate because
what we do know now and something we
didn't know very recently even 10 20
years ago we did not know were there
habitats that could support life
what astronomy has proven in the last
500 years is that the entire universe is
made out of the same stuff right the
most distant galaxies are the same 92
elements that were on the the wall in
your ninth grade classroom right so this
means that if you've taken chemistry in
school you don't have to take it again
if you move to another galaxy it's all
the same everywhere we know that the
building blocks are there we now know
that they're going to be plenty of
planets where you have liquid water and
atmosphere the kind of salubrious
conditions you have in hyattsville for
example so that
life could arise on any of these places
we also know that life began on earth
very very quickly
now it's only a sample of one so that's
not entirely convincing but it does
suggest that it wasn't very difficult
for life to get a foothill a foothold on
this
on this planet so maybe elsewhere so
life i think is maybe uh not so hard to
get started that's sort of the general
impression among scientists but what
they believe is not so important is
finding it that's important the second
part of your question what about
intelligent life that's a lot harder
right
the the earth has had life we know for
at least three and a half billion
probably four billion years almost since
the beginning right this place has been
carpeted with life and almost all of
that time it required a microscope to
see it it was all microbial only in the
last 500 million years did you get
multi-cellular life eventually
trilobites dinos you know the whole
story okay
that
opens up the question well you know if i
give you a million worlds with life what
fraction of them is ever going to cook
up something as clever as you all
and the answer to that is we don't know
the answer to that
however there are indirect suggestions
that it will happen given enough time
simply because we're not the only
species that's gotten clever in the past
50 million years if you have dogs and
cats at home they're clever than the
dinosaurs intelligence does pay off
thank you dr shostak by the way you made
a point that i might emphasize and that
is what 20 years ago we hadn't detected
a single planet outside our solar system
now we're up to close to 2000 so it's
almost exponential growth in
astrobiology research mr wertheimer
i suspect
i suspect the universe is teeming with
microbial life it would be bizarre if we
are alone but i don't know that for sure
the
intelligence is going to be rarer but
because there are trillion planets i i
believe it's going to happen often it's
happened several times on this planet uh
and it's likely to arise elsewhere
as you would put it at a hundred percent
then
99 and yeah 99.999 yeah you strung on
out okay good um the next question mr
worthhammer let me follow up with you
and and by the way as far as the study
at home screensaver goes that would be
something for the students here to take
advantage of as as well as members i
tried to
adapt that to my
laptop in my office several years ago
and was not able to so maybe we'll talk
some more or maybe the government needs
to change its policy i'm not sure
which but let me ask you what are the
advantages and disadvantages of radio
steady versus optical city there are
lots of pros and cons
lasers are good for point-to-point
communication and lots of bits per
second lots of data
i think the best strategy is a multiple
strategy we should be looking for all
kinds of different signals and not put
all our money uh in in one basket
it's hard to predict what other
civilizations are doing if you'd asked
me a hundred years ago what to look for
i would have said smoke signals so we
try to launch a new seti project a new
idea every year
okay and dr shostak anything to add to
the advantages or disadvantages of radio
versus optical study
i should point out that they are both
sort of different colors of the same
thing in fact literally different colors
because they're both electromagnetic
means of communication and we use both
in our telecommunications here on earth
i suspect the aliens will as well i have
to say that just about every week i get
an email from somebody who says you guys
are looking for radio signals that's so
old school
the extraterrestrials assuming they're
out there will use something much more
sophisticated than that and i'm not sure
what that is that depends on physics we
don't know uh it and and one shouldn't
discount a technology simply because
it's been around a while we use the
wheel every day that's a pretty old
technology i suspect we'll continue to
use the wheel for a long time okay and
thank you both for your answers to my
questions and the ranking member ms
johnson is recognized for her questions
thank you very much i'm trying very hard
to
add something that sounds sensible
what is the status of the um
extraterrestrial intelligence and
research now
so
i think we're just getting in the game
we're learning how to do this and i
think we'd be lucky to find even though
i'm i'm optimistic about life and
intelligent life in the universe
uh and it's likely there there's a whole
galactic internet out there uh i think
we'd be lucky to find them now but i'm
optimistic in the long run
congressman johnson uh might point out
that
contrary to popular impression
this experiment isn't the same from day
to day people figure we're sitting
around with earphones you know listening
a cosmic static every day a rather
tedious job if it's if that's what it
were but it's not it's of course all the
listening is done by computers but the
really important point is that much of
this experiment depends on
digital technology computers if you will
and as you know there's something called
moore's law which says that whatever you
can buy today for a dollar you can buy
twice as much for a dollar two years
from now there's this very rapid growth
in the capabilities there so in fact the
search is speeding up and it's actually
speeding up exponentially a very heavily
overused word exponentially but in fact
it applies
uh
to tell me this i know that uh the
improvement of technologies
or
are important and yet some of the old
technologies the old techniques are also
still in play
how do you predict
your advancement
uh
based on what you have available to you
for research tools
i'll just say something i'm sure dan has
much to add to this but
in terms of what we can do in the near
future the foreseeable future what you
really i think need to do if you want to
have a decent chance of success success
in my view this has to remain
speculative i mean this is all like
asking chris columbus two weeks out of
cadiz you know hey have you found any
new continents lately and his answer
would be well there was only water
around the ship today and by the way
also yesterday water around the ship and
tomorrow it's going to be fairly aqueous
in the vicinity of the ship okay
but
so he can't predict when when anything
interesting is going to happen nor can
we but if you look at
what are called euphemistically
estimates and they are guesses as to
what fraction of stars out there have
somebody that you might be able to pick
up it sounds like you have to look at a
few million star systems to have a
reasonable chance of success we can't do
that today we have not done that today
we've done less than one percent of that
as of today okay but given the
predictable advancements in technology
to look at a few million star systems is
something that can be done within two
dozen years given you know the funding
to do it
yes
seth captured it well
now when we find the other life on other
planets what do you speculate we find
and what is the value or potential value
um
i think it's profound either way um this
is this is not an expensive thing of
order a million dollars a year we're
funded by national science foundation
nasa templeton foundation some private
donations
the reason i think it's profound either
way if we if we discover that we are
alone we better take really good care of
life on this planet is very precious
and the other thing is profound too if
we if we are find that we're part of a
galactic community and get on the
galactic internet and learn all their
poetry music literature science uh we
could learn a lot
just add briefly nobody knows what we'll
learn uh if we can decode the signal
this is sort of like being confronted
with the hieroglyphics you know you
might be able to figure them out in the
case of the hieroglyphics wasn't so hard
turns out the hieroglyphics were written
by humans so they made it a lot easier
and there was also the rosetta stone and
whatever so we might not ever figure it
out okay if you could you will be
listening to data being sent by
societies that far in advance of us
because we're hearing them not the other
way around okay so they're more they're
more advanced and maybe they teach you
some very important stuff who knows i
mean imagine that the incas find a
barrel that's washed up on the shore you
know maybe from europe
it's filled with books if they could
ever figure out the books they would
learn a lot of interesting stuff
i don't know that we will ever figure
out the books but even if we don't
the important point has been made and
that is we have calibrated our place not
in the physical universe we've sort of
done that
but calibrated our place in the
biological
and even more the intellectual universe
and i think that that's
maybe good for our souls to know how we
fit in
thank you very much my time
thank you ms johnson uh the gentleman
from ohio mr johnson is recognized for
his question
thank you mr chairman um
gentlemen for for both of you
how has the recent discovery of
over 1700 planets by the kepler space
telescope
uh how has that impacted seti research
um if you'd asked astronomers 20 years
ago other are there planets going on
other stars we said well we think so but
we don't know and that's all change now
and a lot of it's due to the nasa's
kepler mission and if you extrapolate on
the planets which are a few thousand
planets that they've discovered if you
extrapolate on that there are a trillion
planets in the milky way galaxy that's
about three or four times more planets
than there are stars
though that's that a lot of places for
life
okay i think that it's also affected the
experiments in the sense that in the
past we would
point the telescopes in the direction of
stars certain kinds of stars certain
masses of certain brightnesses of stars
those stars were the ones that we
thought these might have an earth-like
planet but we didn't know
we now know two things one is dana's
just mentioned we know that the majority
of stars have planets you can just look
at a random star and feel fairly
confident it has a planet but more than
that we're beginning to get some
indication from kepler what fraction of
stars have planets that are sort of like
the earth and that fraction is not one
in a million it's not one in a thousand
it's not one in a hundred it may be one
in five so you look at you know 50 star
systems and you've examined 10
earth-like planets so in some sense it's
made the search much more
straightforward we just look at all the
nearby stars we can okay uh well doctor
dak would you please provide some
examples of the technical contributions
that seti
has made to astronomy and other fields
for example how has seti research
benefited other areas of science
well i think that its benefit is less so
in terms of the discovery obviously we
haven't found et if we have we wouldn't
be having this hearing okay but
and and to my surprise i have to say
it's not turned up any astrophysical
phenomena
that were unexpected as well okay and
that that's surprising normally the
history the precedent in astronomy is
that every time you build an instrument
that examines a different if you will
parameter in the phase space of the
universe you find something new
so that's instructive that it hasn't the
kind of technology that has been
developed is certainly of interest to
other fields in astronomy but i think
the real value of seti is not so much in
terms of what it does to astronomy but
what it does in terms of the other
efforts being made to find life in space
nasa has a big effort you know the
rovers on mars yes they're there to find
the hydrology the history of water on
mars but why are you interested in the
history of water on mars you're
interested because you want to know
where they're ever martians you know
microbial most likely or are there still
martians that's what interests people
the most okay and seti was always if you
will a punch line to this story that
nasa had about finding you know the
traces of water on mars or burrowing
through the ice on europa and sell it as
some of these moons of the outer solar
system where there may be vast
quantities of liquid water that sort of
thing seti was always said okay
life we may find life but what about
intelligent life that would be even more
interesting and that's what's missing in
fact from the nasa program today okay um
you made a comment just a few minutes
ago that kind of caught my attention let
me make sure i got it right
you said that
if if if we hear
from intelligent life out there
somewhere that
they must be more advanced than us
because we're hearing from them and not
the other way around
how can you draw that conclusion i mean
maybe they've been hearing from us for a
long time and just don't like what we
have to say
uh i i think it's entirely possible that
we are on their in their catalog they've
seen oxygen in our atmosphere and they
know we're out out here and uh
i think life in the universe is is uh
going to be
there's going to be lots of different
stages some of it's going to be
microbial some will be trees more
sophisticated the earth is 5 billion
years old some stars are 10 billion
years old so there could be a lot of
advanced civilizations as well
okay just point out you're not going to
hear from any less advanced societies
and not building radio transmissions
well yeah i'd say i'd say at least equal
to perhaps more advanced but you know
maybe they got their caller id block
turned on or something
it could be i wouldn't speculate on
alien sociology and whether they'd like
our television or not
so i i don't know about that but the
chances that if they're at least at our
level that they're within a hundred or
even a thousand or even ten thousand
years of our level is simply on
statistical grounds highly uncertain if
you hear from somebody they're way
beyond you yeah one one final quick
question uh for both of you how would
you define successful
seti research i mean i know that's a
that's kind of a nebulous
question but but
finding it would be defined successful
if you found a signal and that could be
corroborated if you just find it once
and you can't find it again it's not
science so if you find a signal that's
moving across the sky the way the stars
do because of the rotation of the earth
it's a narrow band signal it's not made
by nature it's made by transmitter
that's success right okay
i think the most likely scenario is
finding some sort of artifact of their
technology a radar signal or a
navigational beacon or something that
won't contain a lot of information but
we'll know we're not alone
okay okay thank you mr chairman i yield
back thank you mr johnson the gentleman
from oregon ms bonamici is recognized
for her questions and if the gentlewoman
will just yield to me for 10 seconds
um it was mentioned a while ago that the
likelihood is if there were other
intelligent civilizations they would
likely be
far in more advanced than we are we're
relatively junior uh galaxy um they
might be two
um i don't know two billion years older
than we are and it's just fascinating to
think what form of life might be
existent in a
in a universe or parallel universe or
another galaxy where they've had a
2 billion year head to start we might
not even recognize
the sentient beings we might not be able
to communicate with them that's
just one of the reasons we're fascinated
by the subject and none of this will be
counted or charged against the general
five minutes for questions
thank you mr chairman and thank you so
much dr shostak and mr wertheimer for
being here
uh i i noticed in your testimony uh mr
wertheimer that you said that there are
24 steady scientists on the planet and i
i can't think of a time in this
committee where we've had a larger
percentage of experts on our panel so
thank you both so much for being here i
really appreciate it and and dr shostak
i i
really am intrigued by your section in
your testimony on the public's interest
and how the idea of life and space is an
idea that everyone grasps and is
especially
ideal hook for interesting young people
in science i think that's evidenced by
the full committee room today
uh one of the state statements that
resonated with me is it would be a
cramped mind indeed that didn't wonder
who might be out there i really
appreciate that
you said also in your testimony
extraterrestrials are the unknown tribe
over the hill potential competitors or
mates but in any case someone we would
like to know more about and i i
recollect a similar hearing uh in this
committee i believe it was last year
when one of my colleagues and i'm fairly
certain it was representative chris
smith who's no longer on the committee
said the interesting question is what do
we do when we find the life on another
planet so can you talk both of you about
what's the plan
do we announce it to the world do we do
research more to determine if these are
friendly or collaborative or
what do we do when we make the discovery
assuming that it's going to happen dr
shostak would you like to begin yes
that's a question of great interest to
the public and of great importance as
well to begin with there's no danger
right i mean you tune in your favorite
dj here in in dc on the car radio and
there's no danger that that dj is going
to jump into the car next to you and
give you a hard time because they don't
know that you've picked them up all
right so if we pick up a signal
they don't know that right there is the
question of well should we
reply i'll get to that in just a second
but what happens then suppose we do pick
up this signal it would be announced the
the public has the idea that you all
have a secret plan that the government
has a secret plan for what to do if we
pick up a signal as far as i can tell
there is no plan okay and we have had
false alarms and i've waited for my
congressman to call me up and say hey
you guys are picking up a signal what
about that and nobody in the government
shows the slightest bit of interest to
be quite honest uh what happens is that
the media start calling up the new york
times will call up right but but the
media are sorry the government is not so
interested so what would happen is that
it would immediately be known that we
had found this signal and it would be
known even before it had been
corroborated so they're going to be
false alarms be prepared for that but
what you do is you get somebody in
another observatory to also observe it
you would not believe it yourself if you
were the only ones to find it there are
too many things that could go wrong okay
mr wertheimer do you have anything to
add to that yeah
i think before you make a big
announcement you want to make sure it's
real
you ask a different a telescope with
different people different software
different equipment to see if they can
verify it
then you
you can triangulate make sure it's
coming from something outside
you make sure it's not a graduate
student playing a prank on you once you
have some confidence that you found
something you may not know what it is it
could be some new astrophysical
phenomena when pulsars were discovered
they thought maybe they'd found little
green men um so i think you then you at
the point where you're pretty confident
that you found something you make all
the information public the coordinates
in the sky uh the frequency anything you
know about the signal and i think
there'll be a lot of debate about
whether there's some new natural
phenomena or this is this is really
evidence of another civilization a lot
of people will be working on that
problem and could you also address uh of
the 24 you say the 24 city scientists on
the planet uh to what extent are
other nations involved how collaborative
are we we have a lot of discussions in
this committee about international
collaboration especially in space so can
you talk about where where we are as a
nation compared with the other
uh countries in the world yeah
seti is quite fragile as you said there
are 24 people doing it there are about
two-thirds of them in the u.s the u.s is
leading this effort and a lot of the
original ideas have come out of the u.s
but
there's uh we are working with other
scientists in other countries and
because it's so fragile we're trying to
train new people and get new ideas and
get other groups because it's only at a
very small number of institutions right
now
the funding is fragile too it's
fluctuating around
the the two biggest telescopes on the
planet are currently funded by the
national science foundation the green
bank telescope in west virginia the
arecibo telescope
those are in funding jeopardy the
it looks like one of those observatories
is probably going to have to be shut
down the other is just hanging by a
thread
um the chinese are building a bigger
telescope there's a new one going to be
built in south africa and australia so
the us may not continue to lead this
this work but it is not i would find
that disappointing if that happened and
i'm out of time i yield back the balance
of my time thank you mr chairman thank
you mr michi and the gentleman from new
york mr collins is recognized for his
question uh thank you mr chairman
i think i might ask the question
everyone in this room wants to ask
have you watched ancient aliens
and what's your comment about that
series
we'll start with you dr shostak yes i
think i've been
on it actually
[Laughter]
more than once the public is fascinated
with the idea that we may be being
visited now or may have been visited in
the past the so-called ufo phenomenon i
personally don't share the conviction
that we are being visited i don't think
that that would be something that you
know all the governments of the world
had managed to obfuscate to keep secret
i don't think i don't believe that
but
the idea that maybe we were visited
during the time of the ancient egyptians
and so forth keep in mind that in the
four and a half billion year history of
the earth the time of the ancient
egyptians was yesterday right so again
why were they there then what was it
that brought them to earth i i have no
idea and i don't find very good evidence
i don't think i think the pyramids for
example were probably built by egyptians
i know that that's a radical idea for
some people
but they were very clever and they could
certainly do that so i don't think that
there's any good evidence that convinces
me
that we were visited in historic times
uh how about you mr wertheimer
um ufos have nothing to do with
extraterrestrials uh so even though i'm
optimistic with life there's no evidence
that any of these sightings i think some
of these sightings are real phenomena we
get a lot of calls when the space
station goes over although some people
embellish and they say it has windows
and things um
and some of it is people's imagination
and we know that because uh it ties very
closely to popular culture when jules
verne wrote about flying saucers
everybody sees started seeing flying
saucers before that people saw angels
when people watch movies then we get a
lot of reports that are tied to what's
in the movies
and some of it is actually deliberate
hoaxes you know for people making uh
making money
yeah
thank you i think that was my only
question mr chairman i yield back
thank you mr collins the gentlewoman
from maryland miss edwards is recognized
for her questions
thank you mr chairman i feel like i
should have been here earlier so i
apologize i've enjoyed the
discussion thus far and
reading the testimony
you know my favorite movie is contact
right so every year it comes out since
1997
i watch it i dream i think well you know
who knows
what's intriguing about this
conversation is the idea that um and it
is a little bit of hubris right that
somehow we're waiting to find them as
opposed to them finding us
um and maybe that's just the nature of
homo sapiens that's kind of what we uh
what we do
but i'm a little bit uh curious
dr wartheimer in your prepared statement
you discuss the panochramatic seti
project which will use six telescopes to
search nearby stars and and stars most
likely to host an exoplanet system
similar to the sun's and so the project
as you describe it would examine a large
portion of the electromagnetic spectrum
spanning from low frequencies through
optical light to detect possible signals
from advanced civilization
how are the target stars that you talked
about identified and how are you going
to coordinate
the use of the six
telescopes uh we are not trying to use
the telescopes all at the same time um
that that's actually hard to do so we
just use a telescope and other groups
are we're working a lot of groups at
universities and observatories but
typically we'll we'll use one telescope
and then a month later we'll use another
telescope and so on that the stars that
we're targeting we instead of targeting
stars that we know have planets because
of kepler spacecraft it looks like all
stars have plants so we're just going to
target the nearest stars
and so that's our plan is
just target the nearby stars
right and you talked also about the um
you know this notion that there are just
sort of 24 of you folks you know most
interested robustly academically you
know studying this but aren't there like
a whole bun there's a whole network of
people out in communities who kind of
feed or fuel
uh some of the research that you're
doing
seth you want to take that one dan dan
refers to me because i don't think we
know the answer to that question
in order to do this it would be like
saying you know
sure there are a few thousand people
looking for the higgs boson but what
about the communities that are feeding
that
if you don't have the instrument it's
very hard to do the experiment and the
the number of instruments involved here
is very small so the rest of us are
really just you know dreaming and
pretending that that's what we're well
that's all right you don't have to
answer that i was not serious at all um
and and then i want to talk about uh
security issues in the time that we have
left um i understand that early on there
was an assessment of the robustness of
the seti home software to withstand
malicious attacks and penetrations and
in the earlier study you found that
there had been two noteworthy attacks
and the web server was compromised you
also found later that exploiting a
design flaw in your client server
protocol that hackers had actually
stolen thousands of you user email
addresses can you give us an idea of the
current state of security
um yeah i think in general downloading
software and installing on your computer
you should be careful it actually turns
out the city at home is is one of the
the safest things you can install on the
computer and the reason is because
millions of people are using it and
testing it out uh and so uh
um so
so it and also it's been running for a
really long time and it's open source
software the software is anybody can
read the software and help us a lot of
the volunteers actually help us write
the software and we're now reporting it
to cell phones so you can run it on a
cell phone which will allow us a lot of
people even more people to participate
in the search
i guess some of the questions just the
challenge when especially whenever you
deal with open source uh the challenge
of the system's vulnerability
yeah i actually think open source
software is actually a little safer
because so many eyeballs can can look at
it
okay i'm done i think i'll just go back
to watching my movies
thank you miss edwards uh the gentleman
from florida mr posey is recognized for
his questions
i thank you mr chairman and and thank
you for inviting these distinguished
witnesses
uh
for this fascinating testimony
very enjoyable
i go to the
seti facebook page every day to
get a little extra factoid
i learned something every day i hadn't i
hadn't been there a single day
to find that i already knew your message
of the day
very
very educational
very inspiring
obviously very interesting and
graphics always good too
and and i want to thank you for that
on your uh disclosure
i was really impressed uh with the
number of agreements and grants
i'm i'm just really glad to know that
that nasa is is so engaged with what
you're doing there
and
still allow you all to have a a pretty
free hand
to do what you do
better i think than than anybody else is
doing it obviously
and and so thank you for that
obviously there's some curiosity about
your thoughts about such things as
project blue book
what do you think
first off i want to thank you for noting
all those grants by the way are for the
astrobiology research being conducted at
the seti institute there's actually no
federal money going to the search for
intelligent life but we do the majority
of our scientists are doing astrobiology
so life on mars the outer solar system
uh in terms of and we're glad you are
yes well so are we i can assure you and
that's i think a very productive
line of research as well uh in terms of
project blue book and the whole ufo
phenomena as i say i am personally quite
skeptical uh one third of americans
believe that we are being visited that's
the
that's the result of polls that have
been taken since the 1960s that number
doesn't change and by the way if you
think this is a
especially american opinion that's wrong
one-third of europeans australians
japanese and so forth believe that we
are being visited i do not i honestly do
not i don't think that that evidence is
very good i think that if we were being
visited it would not be controversial
it's been 60 what 60 some years since
roswell for example if you would ask the
residents of massachusetts 60 years
after columbus do you think you're being
visited by spaniards that would not be
controversial yeah i think that if if
they were really here everyone would
know that
okay very good
um
stephen hawking i believe made some
comments
about contact with
extraterrestrials or or other life your
thoughts about his comments
yeah so
this is a controversial topic about
whether we should transmit messages
that's called active seti or or medi
messages to extraterrestrial
intelligence um
most people in the field think that
we're
just an emerging civilization and the
first experiments we should do is just
listening we trying to receive signals
and see what's out there
we think that advanced civilizations are
going to be peaceful if you watch star
trek but but we don't know that and that
may be naive so
my feeling is that we should be just
listening
for now and maybe in a thousand or ten
thousand years if we don't hear anything
we should think about
transmitting signals but that's a
question for all humanity uh it
shouldn't be just up to a few scientists
and uh
and and and so that that's a big
decision about who should speak for
earth so right now i think we should be
listening and that's i believe that's
what hawking would say as well
i'm going to disagree a little bit with
my colleague here dan i i think that
there's very little danger in
transmitting and if there is we're
already doing it yes we're not
deliberately targeting the stars in
general although we have done that in
the past nasa sent a beatles
uh song in 2008 i believe it was to the
north star and it'll take 450 years to
get there and they may or may not like
the beetles but you know they use a
fairly powerful transmitter but the most
powerful transmitters are coming off the
airports right for air navigation for
the dew line all these things these
signals are on their way into space
they've already reached several thousand
star systems any society that has the
technical competence
to threaten you across dozens hundreds
thousands of light years of space any
society at that level can pick up these
signals so if you're really going to
worry about this you better shut down
all the radars at the local airports and
personally i don't think that would be a
very good idea
okay
um and and briefly uh still related uh
your thoughts on thorium
i'm sorry i'm not familiar with the
topic are you talking about nuclear
reactors
yeah
i'm really not an expert i'm sorry
only this if you're talking about
powering spacecraft this way
you know if you send spacecraft to some
of the more interesting parts of our
solar system they're in the boondocks of
the solar system out to jupiter saturn
and so forth when you get to saturn the
amount of sunlight is dropped by a
factor of a hundred so you can't use
solar cells very effectively out there
you have to power the craft some way i
wouldn't worry too much about
radioactivity in space of course because
space has plenty of radioactivity
that's the nature of the cosmos right
but if you're worried about the fact
that these these launches could go awry
and that you would land these things on
earth yes that's that's a danger but of
course people are aware of that danger
and they try and mitigate it
okay uh thank you mr chairman and thank
both witnesses thank you mr posey the
gentleman from arizona mr schweikert is
recognized for his question thank you mr
chairman and to our witnesses so let's
see what have we learned so far we've
learned there's a chance um
the aliens don't like the beatles
which i have trouble imagining
and they don't like our um television
programming and there was a couple other
things oh yeah and contact is the best
movie right
somehow i thought that would be funnier
um
a couple couple mechanical questions i
just want to sort of get my head around
some of the
um
current scientific understanding um uh
let's walk through a scenario and you
tell me if it's plausible or this is
current thought um asteroid hits the
unite hits the world
you know hits her earth and rock is
thrown out into
you know the stellars
um
it carries dna
does that dna survive
doctor
uh
yes this this idea
known as panspermia i'm sure you're
aware of that the idea that one world
could infect another world has been
looked at people have actually simulated
the environment of space and put some of
our earthly bacteria into a rock and put
it as it were in space to see how long
they could survive for example you know
would the dna still be viable when it
got someplace interesting and the
results as i understand them suggest
that yes if you're talking about you
know communicable disease if you will
within the solar system could a rock
from mars have seeded the earth that
is possible there's no evidence that
that occurred but that is possible the
the life would survive it would remain
viable over the kind of time scales to
send rocks in the solar system from one
world to another but if you're talking
about seeding worlds in other solar
systems at the distances of the stars
the problem is space is a pretty harsh
environment even for a rock because
there's a lot of radiation uh in and
it's incredibly dry so anything that's
in there is going to be suffering
desiccation for maybe hundreds of
thousands millions really of years
before it gets there and the general
consensus that i've heard is that it
won't be viable when it does
thought on that because i think that's
the current sort of thought right now
um yeah so as you know asteroids have
hit the earth many times uh and so uh
it'll be a really interesting question
if if life is found in our own solar
system like for instance europa which is
a moon going around jupiter has a liquid
ocean there could be something swimming
around down there um by the way when i
uh
i talk to elementary schools and i ask
them how we're going to get through the
ice and see if there's something
swimming around down there the uh the
boys all say we should use machine guns
and bombs and the girls say we should
melt our way through using mirrors a
little different but anyway
once again proving there is something in
our dna this is different
the uh
so if we do find life in our own solar
system it'd be really exciting to to
figure out is it exactly the same kind
of life is it use the same dna the same
amino acids the the the same nucleotides
is it identical chemistry that would
mean that that rocks are going back and
forth between
uh these moons and planets in our own
solar system and and uh it really
happened in one place and was carried
back and forth uh what as seth was
talking about that's
not very interesting um what would be
much more interesting would be
discovering life that's different with
the different chemistry because if we do
find something like that
on europa or another moon
or mars
that means that the universe is teeming
with life if we can find it in two
different kinds of life in our own solar
system that means there's a lot of life
out there yeah it makes the imagination
um wonder um earlier the chairman and
i i mean this with all the love in the
world
was trying to say give me a percentage
of life out there in existence i
remember doing this sort of as
a sort of thought process with one of my
professors many years ago
and i guess one of the mechanisms was
it from the beginning to today
earth has had
100 billion species
or or something that and how many can do
higher math
and sort of give you sort of a and we
would use that as sort of a benchmark to
try to do those calculations and i guess
our understanding was
it's unknowable
you know of
what's out there what isn't out there i
mean you know we see the world of large
numbers
large planets
you know these huge numbers
um
on earth intelligence has a written
several times independently there are a
lot of intelligent creatures uh although
known as quite as intelligent as us
maybe we're not sure well we always use
the higher math as the yeah
but
my guess is that on some planets there
are going to be selective pressures that
select for different kinds of things you
can be successful in life if you're
strong or fast uh or
but you can also be successful in some
evolutionary environments by being smart
and so i think they're going to be
places in the universe where it's
advantageous to be smart but
i guess and for doctor
the fun on this one is how would you
ever calculate it
how would you ever sort of build your
baseline to build from and when you move
from sort of hope which is a powerful
thing to
being able to put it into a calculator
there is often a quite a leap i think
it's it
it's very difficult to estimate because
we just have this one example on earth
and so the i think the only way we're
going to find out is to do this search
it's it's very akin i think to sitting
around in the bars of europe 1700 trying
to estimate the probability that any
expedition sent into the deep south
any sailing expedition will find the
hypothesized southern continent there no
you know what what are the probability
can you give me that to three figures
before i fund you you can't
yeah so you have to do the experiment so
therefore it becomes a leap of faith but
it's a reasonable leap of faith it's a
reasonable hypothesis that there's life
to be found out there even intelligent
life to be found out there and we can
sit around and have a lot of drinks and
talk about it but in the end if you
don't do the experiment you'll just
continue to have the drinks oh seeing
some of our questions there may have
been a lot of drinks going on um thank
you mr chairman thank you mr schweiker
dr shostak mr wertheimer thank you both
for your testimony which was clearly
appreciated
by both members of congress as well as
the audience and i also want to thank
the
herndon high school students for being
here today you had a wonderful
opportunity today to hear about a
fascinating subject and i hope this will
spur you on to study not only
astrobiology but other
scientific
subjects as well and in case someone has
an interest or wants to follow up on
this subject you might go to
our committee's website
which is science.house.gov
and we'll clearly have information about
this hearing on that website as
well as
other things that might be of interest
to you all so thanks again for a
wonderful hearing today and we stand
adjourned
foreign
on the next washington journal we'll
look at some of the key issues before
congress